هذا واعرب الاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلقه ازاءه
صعيد الخطير للعنف في الايام الاخيره في
اسرائيل والاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
ولبنان ودعا الى لجم الصراع فورا ودنى
الاتحاد ما وصفها بالهجمات الارهابيه
المميته في تل ابيب الاردن كما دان العنف
الحاصل في الاماكن المقدسه التي قال انه
يجب الحفاظ على وضعها الراهن اضافه الى ما
سماها الهجمات الصاروقيه العشوائيه على
اسرائيل من غزه والاراضي اللبنانيه وقال
ان لاسرائيل الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها لكن
يجب ان يكون هذا الرد متناسبا وفقا البيان
من الناصره ينضم الينا وديع عوده الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي والخبي في الشان
الاسرائيلي سيدنا عوده هذا الموقف المتوتر
الان وان كان الان في هذه الساعات طبعا
يسوده الهدوء لكن هل تعتقد بانه مرشح
لمدينه صعيد
المستوطنين تصب الزيت على النار
لا سيما وان هناك لهم سفراء في الحكومه
وزراء منفلتين حتى اسرائيليا يسمون بمشعلي
النار ولذلك الاوضاع دائما مرشحات طالما
ان هناك احتلال هناك احتكاك والباب مفتوح
امام مثل هذا التصعيد
وبالنظر هنا الى ما ينظر اليه فصائليا على
انه توحيد
للساحات الفلسطينيه هل ترصد بالمقابل ايضا
توحيد بين صفوف الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والمعارضه
ضمن حاله
الانشقاق او التباين الكبير الذي شهدناه
خلال اسابيع الماضيه
نعم تماما هذا موضوع مهم جدا وفي وقت هذا
السؤال
يعني بهذه العزال اقول كالتالي حينما تدخل
ايران او حزب الله على الخط ويكون هناك
شعور لدى الاسرائيليين ان حزب الله او
ايران يقف خلف مثل هذا التصعيد تكون عمليه
اللحمه الاسرائيليه قد
سارعت الاستعاده ذاتها كما كان من قبل هذه
الاحتجات ولكن حينما يقتصر ذلك على ردات
فعل فلسطينيه مقاومه للاحتلال فان هذا لا
يؤثر على استمراريه الانشقاق داخل اسرائيل
ربما اقول بالعكس احيانا نجد ان هناك من
يعتقد ان وجود هذه الحكومه وليس من قبل
اليسار فقط وجود هذه الحكومه هي جزء من
هذا التصعيد نتيجه وجود عدد من الوزراء
غير المجربين الذين كما كنا يسمون بمشعلي
النار الذين لم يخدمون بالجيش ولهم خطط
سياسيه
يبحث عن استبدال اداره الصراع بحسم الصراع
مع الفلسطينيين بنج فير يبحث الى دفع من
اجل ما يعرف بحرب اجوج وماجوج وهذا ما ورد
في النقاشات الاسرائيليه الاخيره ولكن
للاسف انا اقول لك وطبعا بالنسبه لسؤالك
تتمه لهذا الحديث هناك هذه الليله في تل
ابيب تستمر المظاهرات والاحتجاجات هناك
دعوه لتجديد هذه الاحتجاجات وهناك من يقول
ان وجود هؤلاء في داخل الحكومه من وزراء
مغيبيين ومتطرفين وعدميه تجربه وعدمين
مسؤوليه مقابل عمليه تحييد لوزير الامن
الذي يبدو عاقلا ومجربا ومهنيا في تصرفاته
في ادارته الى الازمه هذا يدعو او يعني
يعطي وجبه اكسجين للمحتاجين المتظاهرين
لدعوه الاسرائيليين للمزيد من التظاهرات
والمزيد من الاحتجاجات لكن
المفقود الغائب في اسرائيل عدا اصوات
خافته قليله
لا تزال اسرائيل تبحث عن حلول امنيه هذا
الصوت الذي يكون هناك احتلال هناك استفزاز
لماذا نضع اصابعنا بعيون الفلسطينيين
دعونا نبحث عن حل هذا الاحتلال حل
الاستراتيجي حل الجذري اكاد اقول ان هذا
الصوت لا يزال صوت خافت وقليل شكرا لك من
الناصره ودعواوده الكاتب هو المحلل
السياسي والخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي